so nice to finally meet you spider-man
hi everyone it's Charlie we got a brand
new spider-man far from home promo to
break down with a couple Easter eggs and
news about what's going on with their
marketing as it applies to Avengers
endgame there's a lot of really funny
stuff going on so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's new giveaway stuff
I'll explain at the end of the video
they've released a bunch of new preview
images just hyping up the different
places that they'll go on their world
tour confirming another big place that
we have not seen in any of the trailers
yet so I'll explain what's going on with
that we also found out when they're
dropping the next trailer and it has a
lot to do with what's going on with
Avengers endgame because of really big
spoilers in spider-man far from home so
I'll talk about that in a second we'll
talk about the easter eggs first the
first image is just him on the London
Eye if you haven't been to London before
it's just one of the many big touristy
landmarks that people go to it was also
featured in Fantastic Four 2 so I know
everybody's wondering about what's gonna
happen with the Fantastic Four in the
MCU now that Marvel officially owns
those characters
within the context of spider-man far
from home it's not meant to wink at
Fantastic Four - or anything like that
it's just a common London landmark
pretty much every big movie that goes to
London to film like the big Fast and
Furious movies they all feature the big
London landmarks so of course they're
gonna show up in everybody's big movie
one of the ways movies get big tax
credits is as if they feature a lot of
touristy landmarks so that's why foreign
countries will say come film here we'll
give you a big tax credit if you help
tourism in our country there was a lot
of London footage in the last big
trailer that's why you see all those big
monuments in that because they turn
those into big action scenes just big
wide sweeping shots almost like they're
doing a tourism ad for the City of
London you see Nick Fury in The Shard
which is the tallest building in the UK
looking down on London City keeping his
one eye on spider-man and everything
that's going on in his field of view you
see Tower Bridge which actually isn't
too far away from that in that big
action scene where he jumps off in the
new version of the suit to go fight that
monster Parker the funny thing about
this scene is it's actually a solid
chance that Spiderman could be talking
to Nick Fury in his ear because the
shard is right over here he would be
able to see everything that's going on
during this big battle if he were up in
that building the next one is actually
interesting because it's spider-man at
the Brandenburg Gate in Berlin Germany
and as far as we know we haven't seen
any footage of them in Berlin in any of
the trailers because when they have that
funny scene of them in customs that's
actually Italian custom so that's when
they're headed to Venice which is
featured prominently during the trailer
because it's where that big Mysterio
battle takes place with the Hydra
monster so we have no idea what they're
doing in Berlin if it has anything to do
with the events of Captain America Civil
War because that was the last time the
Spider Man was in Berlin they did that
that special office of the world
security council where Iron Man was
working out up with the government in
Everett Ross like there was a lot of
stuff going on that was Avengers related
in Berlin so we could have something to
do with that they could just be drawing
on resources because this is a very
international movie with international
problems and I'll talk about this when I
talk about the next trailer but it
implies that Nick Fury is taking a more
prominent authority role because as of
the end of Avengers infinity war it
still seemed like shield had not
reformed officially within the MCU and
he and Maria Hill
still kind of working on the DL on their
own the scale of the threat and
spider-man far from home and this the
way he presents himself to spider-man
makes it seem like he's acting in a more
official capacity like he has a lot more
resources like he used to when he was
director of shield post all your
theories about what you think is
happening in Berlin Germany during the
movie so far we haven't had any kind of
evidence there haven't been any rumors
or anything so it's just another big
location with a big question mark over
it the third image is just him in the
Venice canals in Italy where he fights
the Hydra monster with Mysterio that's
where you see most of the footage during
the last big Spider Man far from home
trailer the place where their hotel is
where they're all watching on the news
where Flash Thompson reveals that he's a
total spider-man stand and says what's
up dickwad to Peter Parker not
understanding that he is spider-man
sup dickwad moving into the next trailer
everybody asking when are they gonna
drop more footage the funny thing about
that is they said that they're not gonna
be releasing another big spider-man far
from home trailer until we get closer to
Avengers endgame because as you would
assume there are gonna be a bunch of
spoilers in it for the end of Avengers
endgame they're already couple key plot
points that we've seen them teased at
the beginning of the last trailer
especially with that check regardless of
when this actually happens during the
movie whether this is the beginning or
it's happening closer to the end there's
just a lot of questions raised about why
Happy's here why Pepper Potts name is on
this check why Iron Man isn't anywhere
to be found so I just broke these down
top eight Styles just to address these
eight you know obviously what happens to
Iron Man peppers clearly alive because
their names on the check happy still
seems like he's fine because he's
flirting with Aunt May just freakin
spider-man out there's also the scene of
the two of them flying on Iron Man's
automated jet just like they did during
Captain America Civil War and Spider Man
far from home this could be happening
when they're in London he could be just
flying him somewhere temporarily because
for the most part he's traveling with
his classmates through the film they fly
to Europe on a regular passenger jet
just like everyone else so at some point
in the film happy will have to take him
somewhere else that could have something
to do with him getting those new
versions of the suit 7 it'll spoil what
happens to New York City that makes Iron
Man want to give his own money to help
the homeless because that's what's
happening in the beginning of the
trailer here they're benefiting the
homeless in and around the New York City
area
but you remember outside of his Avengers
activities Iron Man is just a regular
billionaire in the world he probably
gives a lot of
money to charity normally big man in a
suit of armor
take that off what are you genius
billionaire playboy philanthropist so
what about this time is so special that
he wants to make a special check and
have Spider Man give it to the people
obviously he's being the friendly
neighborhood spider-man they sort of pay
that reference off at the end of the
trailer of Flash Thompson says what he
wears a dope suit he protects the
neighborhood that just a reference to
friendly neighborhood spider-man
whatever it is that's happening in this
moment here it's because of something
that happens at the end of Avengers end
game six what happens to Captain America
whether or not he sacrifices himself and
if that means that he dies or winds up
in a limbo state a la soul gem or just
disappears into eternity and everybody's
not really sure what happens to him five
the trailer will have to spoil how Nick
Fury comes back at the end of Avengers
endgame I know a lot of questions about
what's going on with Nick Fury in a lot
of these scenes people are wondering if
he's not really Nick Fury and is someone
else pretending to be him we just had
Captain Marvel I know there's lots of
questions about Secret Invasion and
Scrolls I'll talk about that in a
separate video I do not think that Nick
Fury is a scroll in spider-man at far
from home but because the chameleon is
supposed to be a character during the
movie people are just wondering if it's
secretly the chameleon pretending to be
Nick Fury just working with Mysterio
there's the very comic book subplot
going on and far from home where
Mysterio is trying to make himself look
like a hero like he does in the comics
when really he's a course spider-man
villain so he's going to be a master
manipulator during the film manipulating
Nick Fury and manipulating spider-man
until spider-man figures out what's
going on for the trailer we'll have to
reveal what happens to shield like Nick
Fury has all these resources again does
that mean that he's back in charge of
shield whether or not they bring shield
back during Avengers end game there are
behind the scenes pictures of Iron Man
in shield gear during Avengers end game
but I think that this is a little
misleading I'll talk about that when we
get more Avengers end game footage three
they'll have to reveal how the Avengers
in Spider Man inspire Mysterio to become
Mysterio based on the events of Avengers
endgame in the last couple of Avengers
movies so think about it this way they
fix everything but there's still a final
big battle that's very public the
avengers save the day everybody loves
them and it becomes one of the tipping
points in Mysterio's life that says I
want to be just like this I want people
to love me so forgetting about the
years later issued during spider-man far
from home from the original Avengers
battle remember the way they used the
original battle of New York during that
movie to inspire all the villains in
present-day the way they use technology
just all the fallout from that original
Avengers movie
so think about someone like Mysterio who
was watching all those Avengers battles
following them all over the world
growing more and more delusional about
how the world could love him the same
way that they loved the Avengers and
that starts off the plot of spider-man
far from home with these different
creatures that he creates - spider-man
far from home we'll have to spoil
whether or not they opened the bottle on
multiple realities in Avengers end game
because the way that Mysterio is
explaining these elemental creatures is
that they're basically supernatural and
the world as we know it right now
doesn't totally understand that even
after the events of the Doctor Strange
movie most regular people have no idea
what Doctor Strange does what other
realities and dangers like Dormammu that
he's protecting them from so if Mysterio
comes out in a really public way making
everyone think that all these multiple
realities exist with these elemental
creatures even though I think we all
believe that this is fake that means
that people will suddenly realize on
mass scale oh my god we're not the only
thing living here there are other
realities there's mystical stuff going
on in number one one of the other big
things the Spider Man far from home is
going to spoil is what's going on in the
background post snap and Avengers
endgame things left hanging in the air
other potential spider-man villains that
are showing up just things that
reference just how much the world has
changed in Avengers endgame and how the
Avengers fix everything so as you can
understand there's so many unanswered
questions as of the beginning of
Avengers endgame even the footage that
we've seen which kind of reveals quantum
suits so we have kind of an idea of
what's going on but really if the movies
gonna be longer than two and a half
hours because people think that it's
gonna be up to three hours there's so
many things that can happen in that run
of times that they just want to wait til
after everybody sees it before they show
you what's going on in spider-man far
from home in this new post Avengers
endgame Marvel phase four world everyone
post your theories in the comments what
do you think that spider-man far from
home is gonna spoil about Avengers end
game there is a new round of that IMAX
ticket giveaway - as long as you're a
subscriber to my channel all you have to
do to enter is leave a spider-man
related comment on the video there's a
whole bunch of really big comic-book
stuff coming up in the next couple of
days so I'll post all those video
as fast as possible click here to
rewatch both of those different versions
of the spider-man far from home trailer
and click here for my non-spoiler East
Shazam review thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]